[Music]
hi everyone i'm sophia product manager
from google cloud i'm here today to tell
you about cloud asset inventory
well i'll know by bringing workload to
cloud you're benefiting from its
scalability high performance secureness
and cost efficiency
yet at the same time admins especially
platform admins secure elements are
facing never before seen challenges they
were brought in by the large
quantitative resources and data that can
be easily created by developers
in fact enterprises have millions of
resources running on google cloud today
so how can you see all the things you
have on cloud at the same time how can
you keep an eye on all the changes as
they happen so you don't miss a threat
how do you answer questions that seem
simple but actually challenging like
how many vms do i have in my org
who can change my billing accounts
or what service account keys that are
older than 60 days
i'm very excited to introduce your cloud
assign inventory that aim to solve all
these challenges for you as you can see
here cloud assign inventory is a fully
managed metadata service
so let's first address the elephant in
the room what is an asset
an asset can be a resource like a vm
instance a bigquery table
it can also be a policy like impolicy or
policy
it can also be vm random information
like system updates
so now let's talk about metadata
metadata here means the configuration of
the asset not the actual customer
content
for example it is about the name the
size creation time for the disk but not
the files that are written on the disks
it offers many even trade services on
your entire gcp and enthalpy environment
which makes it truly a one-stop shop
so you don't need to go to computer
engine to find all your vms and then go
to cloud storage to see all your buckets
for example
and what is more convenient than that it
works at the organization folder and the
project level with find green and policy
controls so regardless of your
permission level you can always take a
full advantage of it
lastly you can get up to 35 days of full
change history from cloud asset
inventory
now let's dive deeper into the features
first and foremost you can get a
snapshot of your entire inventory you
can use either the export or the lisa
service
the difference is that
export is a long-running operation which
will export your data to either a cloud
storage bucket or a bigquery table which
makes it easier for you to directly
query and analyze data later
this api works just like any other lease
api except it supports a timestamp
where all the data will be included in
the standard http response in case you
don't want to deal with a storage
location you can also get a full change
history by either using the ui or api
which i'll demo later
now after getting full visibility for
your entire inventory plus history
we also offer real time notification
feature for you to easily achieve
continuous monitoring
it allows you to monitor assets and will
send a pops-up message when change
occurs
you can define your criterias by as a
name as a type or by org folder and
project you can even use cell condition
and by the way cell is expression
language that created by google
for example you can say notify me as
soon as any file rules got changed in my
org
or notify me only if my policy is
changed to be open or when a vm's
deleted
here's an example scenario an admin
wants to monitor and get notified when a
gmail account is added to an end policy
you'll first define your condition in a
real-time feed using the code shown
below
now if a malicious user adds his own
gmail account into the policy cloud
asset inventory will trigger cloud pops
up message right to you in real time
from there you can define your own
remediation actions for example you can
write a cloud function to reorder back
the change or send an email to project
owners the real-time monitoring
capability especially the conditions
supported through cell ensures that you
won't miss any important changes and
also filters out the noises so you can
stay focused and keep your costs low
okay now if you're one of the policy
admins or privacy admins who have to be
on top of access grants take care of
access certificate and keep track of all
the changes across your whole org you
will be really excited to learn a
powerful tool offered about cloud asset
inventory i am policy analyzer
in a nutshell it does deep and thorough
analysis on policies and related
resources to help you answer the
question who can access what and why
for example what service accounts can
access my buckets that contain sensitive
data or what access does this terminated
employee still has
so what makes the tool powerful let me
show you with the actual example
who can change my firewall rules
this is one of the top questions adam
need to answer and keep track to
well turns out you have to peel through
many layers to actually get to the full
picture
starting from the whole part
who can be a user a group or even a
service account
in the case of group there can be
multiple layers of groups which we call
nessus groups in case of a service
account there can also be multiple
layers of service accounts that can
impersonate one another
policy analyzer can handle all of the
above to give you a complete picture on
the whole part
now let's look at what's needed for
changing a variable rule
turns out three permissions create
update or delete can all make changes to
firewalls in some ways
policy analyzer is capable of mapping
item rules to permissions for both
security rules and custom rules
and last let's look at the last part of
the question project a
we all know iom policies can be
inherited which requires you to not only
look at and policy directly on project a
here but also trace up along the
hierarchy to the folders and the orgs
above to make sure all the policies are
analyzed
luckily policy analyzer analyzes
resource and the policy hierarchy as
well
it also analyzes im conditions and
exports results to cloud storage buckets
or bitcoin table
so here you go you can see how much work
the policy analyzer does for you behind
the scene in order to provide a truly
complete and comprehensive answer on who
can access what and why
now it's the demo time as i mentioned
earlier let's take a quick look at the
cloud asset inventory developer console
the cloud asset inventory developer
console is located under the iem and
admin tab first you can use the toggle
on the top to switch between org folder
or project that would like to see your
asset set
once landed on the landing page you will
see an overview tab with automatically
pre-populated dashboards for your
deployment insights also resource and
and policy tabs for details about assets
the first geograph shows you how your
zonal and original resources are located
across the globe you can also get to a
table view of it
the next one shows how your vm instance
accounts have been changing over time
and the next field shows you the
resource console-based services and
asset types
you can also use the predefined filters
on the left to focus only on assets
you're interested in like vm instances
you can see i have 17 and they all live
in the u.s central region
click anywhere on the dashboard it will
take you to the corresponding resource
and policy tab you can see here all the
field options are carried over from the
graph setting before so let's uncheck
them
let's assume i want to search for
certain vm instances so i can first
check an asset type here and then i will
further refine my search results by
typing the search term into the search
bar like name contains the instance and
then label key contains color group
and here are my results
i can also search by directly typing in
the certain asset attribute values like
unknown external ip as that's what i
found on the internet i want to locate
which vm it is
and here you go i found my vm
i can then click on the instance to see
the detail page you can see the high
level summary first
also if compute engine vm manager is
enabled you can see the runtime
information as well like os version
kernel running or stopped
you can go to the change history tab to
see the full change history up to 35
days
you can see here all the time stamps
shows the ones that had a metadata
change
and i can choose two time stamps to
compare the differences
in this case i can see that a label
color group pink was removed between the
two versions
as well as some other change
next you can go to the full metadata
type for all the details like a
description disk service account etc
and lastly you can see the m policy
that's attached to the resource in the
impolicy tab
that is all for today and we encourage
all of you to try it out
check out the documentation product
pages down below and we're looking
forward to hearing from all of you thank
you very much for watching
[Music]
you